welcome to et Canada pride I'm Stephen a
producer here at et Canada and this is
the first episode of our brand-new
digital series we wanted to create a
space for the LGBTQ community and our
allies to come together discuss hot
topics the latest headlines and
entertainment and obviously the woman
beside me needs absolutely no
introduction I'm so happy and thrilled
to have miss gia gunn here with me
hi Jo hey thank you so much for having
me it's such a great honor and how
exciting how it's a very first episode
I'm truly honored well I'm really
excited to have you here as our first
guest because I think that you have one
of the most incredible journeys from
drag race tell me about that experience
and coming back for all-stars for when I
got the call for all-stars my immediate
reaction was absolutely not just because
I felt myself distancing from drag and
kind of wanting to dive in to more
activism and really you know just
digging deep into who I am as a person
outside of drag drag has done so much
for me personally and my career but I
definitely was at a moment where I felt
myself kind of going in a different
direction but after you know lots of
time with thinking and contemplating I
really realized what a big opportunity
this was not for me only and for me to
be back on TV again but to bring trans
visibility on you know this show that
has international exposure and has such
influence on you know young people our
youth and just everybody in the world
drag was the gateway for me to realize
that I am NOT a man that dresses up as a
woman I'm a woman that participates in
the art of drag I always connected the
gia Gunn because you did like to stir
the pot quite a bit I'd rather do what I
want to do well what you want to do
not necessarily what you're gonna do by
versa
cool do you regret anything that
happened
do you regret any words that were
exchanged you know what I don't I really
don't live my life in regret I don't
think life is meant to live you know
looking backward I think everything that
we do is a learning experience
everything that we do you know is what's
supposed to happen in life and it's okay
to either make mistakes or you know say
things that maybe that you wish that you
didn't say or that were put into a
different context because it is a
television show and editing does take
over but no I don't regret anything I
think I was true to myself I think I
still gave the gia gun that people
really fell in love with on season six
with also bringing this you know gia
Gunn
2.0 trans visibility moment to the show
and and I think it all meshed well
together and I definitely think that my
storyline came full circle and at the
end of the day I'm very one of those
personalities where either you love her
or you hate her so well I love her and I
mean fan reaction fans for RuPaul's Drag
Race are severe it's like the day and I
know a lot of girls get attacked online
they do how do you deal with those
haters because some of the things people
say are quite vicious honey it's real
simple
it's hi hater bye hater and you keep on
movin nobody likes to receive hate you
know over social media or hate mail or
be told you know go kill yourself or you
know they say really harmful toxic and
just negative things and for a show that
represents the total opposite it's like
are you really a fan you know were you
ever really a fan it's like these spins
I don't know sometimes really jump
around with you know what side of the
fence they're on but I think at the end
of the day if you're certain of who you
are you're unapologetic about the things
that you do and and and what you put out
into the world I think you know another
hater is just somebody else you know
with your name in their mouth and that
in
this business that's what we need so
honey keep that name rolling around that
dirty little mouth and I live this is a
television show yeah I don't think like
the gia Gunn that's sitting with me
right now isn't necessarily the gia Gunn
that I see on RuPaul a one-hour every
week
exactly and I think fans don't really
understand that sometimes well if we did
see this person I would be called boring
right and I'd be called lackluster I
really wanted to show all sides of me on
all stars as I think you know some
people's idea of being transgender it's
like I think they confuse it with like a
transformation you know they think that
you're going like from one thing to
another and it's like man to woman like
date at night and it's like it's not
like that it's a transition which means
I'm still the same person you know yes
I've learned a few things yes my
priorities and and and and way of seeing
life are different and yes my you know
physical appearance and my lifestyle is
different but the end of the day you
know we're people and I think it's about
what lies in the heart and and who you
are you know and this is who I am what
do you think still needs to be done in
people's perception of what it means to
be trans first and foremost I think it
starts with in the community so I think
right now where we struggle is a lot of
transgender people are not really
outwardly sharing their story they're
not really speaking about their journey
which is okay because you know I think a
lot of people obligate trends people to
be activists when realistically trans
people don't transition to walk out and
say why used to be a Boyar I used to be
a girl but now on this you know it's
kind of like not the whole point of why
I did this anyway I certainly didn't
transition to come on national TV and
say well actually I was born as that you
know it's actually a
dark you know very personal and
emotional thing to talk about for people
and it can bring up some inner turmoil
than some you know dark moments which I
think for a lot of trans people they try
to erase those times and just move
forward but I think with time we are
seeing more trans people becoming more
visible more open to talk about their
journeys and and that's so beautiful and
I think that's what we need we have so
much youth that is struggling with just
accepting who they are and I think show
the group pause drag race you know
definitely give people a sense of
inspiration thanks jia
i and everyone really appreciate what
you're doing for the LGBTQ community
let's keep the conversation going it's
so important to keep the conversation
going yeah but we want to hear from you
who would you like to see visiting us at
et Canada pride is there a topic you
feel passionate about how do you feel
about the interview with Jia let me know
in the comments below and be sure to
LIKE and subscribe to e to Canada's
YouTube page for more